l'électrification des transports permet
de réduire des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dans le cas des véhicules
routiers c'est déjà bien l'engager mais
pour les aéronefs c'est plus difficile
voici toutefois un exemple de travaux de
recherche prometteurs
après la voiture l'hélicoptère
lui aussi passez en mode électrique elia
une effervescence aujourd'hui sur la
planète pour l'électrification de l'air
au spatial qu'on parle d'hélicoptères
qu'on parle d'avion qu'on parle de
véhicules sans pilote capable de piques
seriez pourquoi parce qu'on veut réduire
l'impact environnemental de nos produits
la voiture électrique a mis des
décennies avant de sillonner nos routes
alors avant qu'un hélicoptère électrique
n'atteigne les performances d'un
appareil au kérosène il faudra patienter
mais on y travaille
c'est pas comme l'automobile où on peut
arrêter sur le bord de la rue si on a un
problème en vol on peut pas se permettre
donc on va qu'on doit avoir des niveaux
de sécurité etc sont équivalents à ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui dans l'aviation
avant d'électrifier le rotor principal
on commence par plus petit le retour de
q
tel un gouvernail il permet de diriger
l'appareil pour l' oeil non averti
ce n'est pas frappante
mais pour l'expert c'est évident ce
retour de cul est différent c'est un
rotor de queue électrique on le nomme
date
des le texte- rond abandonne ici le
traditionnel rotor de queue pour le
remplacer par quatre ventilateurs
c'est le coeur de cette innovation
ce type de projet d'habitude ça peut
prendre deux ans ou plus en effet le
chargent de faire le plus tôt possible
plus rapidement possible de le voler
dans une eau alors on savait qu'il
fallait prendre des décisions très
rapidement on lance le programme de
recherche en 2018 l'objectif n'est pas
de commercialiser la technologie
électrique mais d'en démontrer la
viabilité
qu'on avait commencé on savait même pas
si ça allait voler en effet aucune idée
si on était capable de construire une
machine de même c'était vraiment idées
sur papier alors on voulait tester le
concept mais il testé le concept sur une
application très réel
rapidement les ingénieurs envisagent de
concevoir un système à plusieurs et
lisse ce réseau ventilateur al'avantage
d'être léger réactif et moins bruyant en
soufflerie on teste une cinquantaine de
configuration des lices
4 était le système optimal pour la
démonstrateur aujourd'hui battant qui en
panne de deux unes des moteurs il ya
encore les trois autres alors un peu
atterrir en sécurité
pour toutes les décisions qu'on a pris
on savait pas qu'est-ce que nous attend
dès la semaine prochaine puis le mois
prochain c'est il y avait beaucoup
d'inconnues dans sept projets il a dû
convertir une systèmes mécaniques et
systèmes électriques et tout autour de
validation de ce système là était notre
plus gros défi
[Musique]
électrifier le rotor de queue c'est bien
mais au passage les ingénieurs de belles
textron décide de régler d'autres enjeux
le bruit par exemple notamment parce que
sur un hélicoptère le rotor de queue est
la principale source de bruit
les travaux aboutissent rapidement à un
prototype le date se compose de quatre
hélices jumelées deux par deux chaque et
liste contient quatre pales on installe
sur un modèle d'hélicoptère on amorce
ensuite les essais au sol sans décollage
printemps 2010 9 - donnant s'est écoulé
depuis le lancement du projet c'est le
premier test en vol
l'espace réservé aux passagers elne
étant occupé par des appareils de
télémétrie
à quelques mètres dans la salle de
télémétrie une dizaine de spécialistes
s'activent chacun vérifie une vingtaine
de paramètres critiques pour qu'une
alarme c'est un go
pendant le vol l'appareil générait des
données qui étaient transmises à deux
salles de télémétrie où on avait des
spécialistes techniques qui regardaient
les paramètres ou s'assurer que chaque
étape du vol reste est sécuritaire
les ventilateurs électriques
fonctionnent à différentes vitesses ce
qui permet de mieux contrôler le débit
d'air un atout qui augmente la stabilité
du fuselage et la manoeuvrabilité de
l'appareil un rotor de queue
conventionnelle fonctionne toujours à
pleine vitesse
car il est lié ou rotor principal ici
c'est le contraire chaque ventilateur
est alimenté par son propre moteur le
tout est contrôlé électriquement plutôt
que par des liaisons mécaniques
la première phase du programme a permis
d'accumuler 25 heures de vol
fort de son succès dell passe à la phase
suivante date 2.0 il faut optimiser
raffiner les systèmes
exemple les pales connaught à chacune
des hélices comment on peut changer le
matériel pour réduire le poids la façon
de les fabriquer parce que si on veut un
jour commercialisé edat il faut réduire
le poids il faut réduire le coût et
avoir une bonne cadence de production et
tout l'aspect aussi de développement de
batteries les batteries aujourd'hui sont
encore très présentes qu'a-t-on pas
d'une autre puissance qu'on a besoin au
niveau de sécurité qu'on a besoin pour
les batteries alors on va introduire des
technologies hybrides électriques avant
de complètement électrifié
le date est un tremplin un prototype qui
servira à différents types de véhicules
volants quand on fait une technologie
pourri date on regarde aussi quelles
peuvent être les autres
utilisateurs la technologie sombre
l'objectif c'est d'améliorer
l'hélicoptère en général
bientôt le ciel deviendra une autoroute
une autoroute où la circulation sera
moins bruyante et surtout moins
polluantes
[Musique]